mais non
[Musique]
Ne laissez pas les carrières d'hélicoptères
ceux-ci ont
désolé chers frères
Nous vous parlons au nom de l'État.
nous sommes une coalition de fonctionnaires
police militaire et civils
dans la recherche de l'équilibre et
contre ce gouvernement de transition
criminel
nous n'appartenons pas et nous n'avons pas tendance
politicien partisan, nous sommes nationalistes
patriotes et institutionnalistes
ce combat
ce n'est pas
avec le reste des forces de sécurité
de l'État
C'est contre l'impunité imposée
pour ce gouvernement
[Musique]
les gens
à la force armée nationale bolivarienne
toute la
Je me suis activé pour défendre le droit à
tranquillité d'esprit et soyez assuré que
tôt ou tard, nous capturerons
l'hélicoptère et ceux qui l'ont fait
cette attaque terroriste armée contre le
les institutions du pays ont condamné cela
attaque terroriste et j'exige cet amour
condamner cet acte de violence
éminemment